former Federal Reserve chairman Ben
Bernanke he was just on television gave
an interview and of course they had to
ask him about Bitcoin and he had some
wild things to say before I go ahead and
share my opinion let's just hear what
Ben had to say for himself here's the
video Bitcoin and other currencies
cryptocurrencies whose value changes
minute to minute they've been successful
as a speculative asset and people you're
seeing the downside of that right now
but they were intended to be a
substitute for Fiat money and I think in
that respect they have not succeeded
because if if Bitcoin were a substitute
for Fiat money you could use Bitcoin to
go buy your groceries and the main use
of Bitcoin is is mostly for underground
economy activities and things that often
things that are illegal or illicit I
don't think that Bitcoin is going to
take over as an alternative form of
money you don't buy into the idea of it
as being a store of value or some kind
of version of digital gold gold has
underlying use value you can use it to
fill cavities uh the underlying use
value of Bitcoin is to do ransomware or
something like that so one of the other
risks that Bitcoin has is that it could
at some point be subject to a lot more
regulation now of course after watching
that you're either cringing or you're
laughing because there's only one of two
different emotions you could have this
guy used to be an Insider of the Federal
Reserve he was about as close to the
money printer as you could possibly get
and of course because of the cantalonian
effect he ended up profiting from it now
put that aside for one second let's look
at Bitcoin some of the statements that
he made they're just factually
inaccurate he made a statement that most
of the Bitcoin activity is for illicit
purposes but we have people like the
former acting director of the CIA who's
gone on to the blockchain analyzed the
transactions and come out to an
estimation that point four percent of
all transactions are for nefarious or
illicit purposes that means that less
people use on a percentage basis Bitcoin
for illicit purposes compared to US
Dollars and Fiat currencies where it's
estimated that two trillion dollars a
year is just for money laundering now of
course if we then go and we look at
things like gold he talks about the fact
that gold has value because you can use
it to fill your cavity if that's really
why you think gold has value then you're
an idiot ultimately what we've got to
remember is that yes gold is used for
all sorts of different Manufacturing
measuring purposes but it's less than 10
percent of the use of gold gold is
served as a store of value for centuries
and ultimately Bitcoin has been
outperforming gold dollars and pretty
much every other asset on the planet for
the last decade Bitcoin is used by 150
million people or more and to say that
it's failed is comical to say that it's
not a store of value when it's
outperformed all the other stores of
value means that you don't know what
you're talking about and then to even
say things like you can't use Bitcoin to
literally go and buy things at the
grocery store yet at the Bitcoin
conference we saw Jack marlers and
Strikes say we've literally partnered
with NCR and Blackhawk and we're
bringing it to all the top retailers for
everyone from Shopify all the way down
to Starbucks Walmart McDonald's so I
don't know exactly where Ben Bernanke
wants people to be able to spend Bitcoin
but obviously in those stores you're
able to use the Bitcoin Network and that
payment system to go ahead and buy the
goods and services now of course this
goes back to the classic quote never
expect a man to understand something if
his salary depends on his ignorance and
so I actually think that Ben vernacki
understands Bitcoin really well he
probably has done a bunch more work on
it than he's letting on and he may even
be convinced that there is some value
there but the more important thing is
that he's trotted out on national
television and he shares all the Talking
Points the problem is that his talking
points are back from 2014. if he's gonna
be a Critic at least come up with the
new ones things like ESG concerns and
others but instead he's just using the
old regurgitated things that have been
disproven time and time again the worst
part about this is that people would
actually have more trust in these types
of bureaucrats if they simply came out
and they said hey Bitcoin seems to be
pretty interesting the technology is
obviously being adopted by people I
don't think it's going to be nearly as
big as those people think but I do see
that it has value and I can understand
in an environment where there's
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
many of these individuals are looking
for a store of value that they can hold
on to now of course that's not what he's
saying and therefore nobody trusted him
already because of some of the passwork
that he be done but now even more people
are starting to see that Bitcoin simply
exposes the mindset of the bureaucrats
thought about seeking the truth it's not
about actually looking at the data it's
simply about regurgitating the exact
same talking points over and over and
over again but ultimately their opinion
doesn't matter neither does mine and
neither does yours the market is the
ultimate referee and so far according to
the market Bitcoin is winning it's the
best performing asset over the last
decade it's been adopted by 150 plus
million people around the world and it
continues to settle billions and
billions and billions of dollars of
transactions every single day regardless
of what anyone in the world thinks
Bitcoin continues to produce block after
block after block of transactions and no
one's opinion can stop that